primère avec laquelle vous avez commencé
c'est là où on apprend à compter à
écrire à lire aussi à se comporter c'est
là où on apprend des valeurs je suis
totalement favorable à ce qu'on apprenne
la Marseillaise au primaire totalement
c'est même indispensable parce que c'est
ce qui nous unit c'est le fruit de notre
histoire à ce qu' est donc l'heure
sanctuarisée si je puis dire de ds la 5e
d'instruction civique avec un programme
qui est redéfin et qui permet de bien
mieux connaître à la fois l'histoire de
notre nation notre république de nos
institutions et nos grands textes bien
sûr bien alors ouis
alors déjà appliqué mais ça c'est bien
la prendre c'est bien du moment qu'on la
chante pas ça me va très bien
magoige pas qu'on oblige les enfants
queas problème avec la
marseilliseèmeanceème FR Marise ch veux
pas
chanter tu veux mais tu Tu Vi te trahir
a raison JeanMichel Jean-Michel s'il te
plat de chanter la mer tu je veux bien
qu'on
apprne peux laissir ma phrase ou je ne
veux pas que les enfants soient obligés
de chanter
la parce que
obligation aucun j'adore la Marseillaise
C
obligation pas qu'on oblige les enfants
à quoi
so- est-ce que tu veux pas qu'on les
oblige aussi à chanter une souris
ver attendsends donc il a un problème je
ils onoit de Ch oblig àendre un poème
e marseise il veut pas qu'on les oige
pouroi je veux pas qu'on oblige ma fille
à chanter la
Marseillaise franais l' de la France de
la
France Mo
je mais tu pas la France tu veux
divis non mais si non mais si tu assumes
pas l' de
la donc non je l'adore je tu ne veux pas
que ta file chante non pas qu'elle soit
obligée de la chanter
onblige
c'est quoi tème à
l'écoleécole tu fais ce tu
dis tuux bienon oblige les enfants à
chanter
ludque Mar
pour je ne veux pas qu'on oblige les
enfantème tu sa quoi comme tu es dans
l'impass contre
patriotismejà ave ce que tu viens de
dire habill en bleu blanc rouge mais tu
veux pas qu'on a ch c'est l'obligation
qui ne me plaît pas vous
comprz à l'école à l'école quand on
t'oblige à apprendre un poème par et
l'Étap de multip ça fait partie du cours
ça fait partie du cour et d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron est subtile il a dit à
apprendre la marsaise il a pas dit à la
ch c'est évident non c'est pas évident
du
tout tu as tu veux que je te dise là tu
viens de montrer une fois de plus tu
avais un problème tu veux pas le dire
parce que comme tu veux pas en fait je
vais t'expliquer ce qui se passe tu veux
pas fâcher euh ceux qui ne veulent pas
chanter la Marseillaise donc là tu l'as
fait un petit peu tu nous l' fait à
l'envers une fois de plus à la Gill
verdeise hein tu nous fais une boulette
he tu nous fais une chque Choua pour
dire oui mais non mais si B je veux dire
tout le monde est d'accord avec moi ici
Valérie benim Géraldine Jean-Michel tout
le monde donc tu nous fais une cha Choua
pour dire je vais pas me [__] dans la
merde avec ceux voilà qui veulent pas
chanter la marillaise mais je vais pas
me [__] dans la merde avec ceux qui
disent donc je vais dire je veux bien on
apprenne la marceillaise on la
chante tu connais Mar
mais arrête tes
conneriesobligé une fois de plus une
fois de plus tout les jours à 19h55 je
vois ta mal je ne veux pas qu'on oblige
les enfants à porter l'uniforme à
chanter la marcielle je ne veux
pas dis Marange parce qu'en fait on
t'entend et en fait il y a des
souscouches un peu hypocrites en fait
j'aimerais que tu
dises si non non elle est pas hypocrite
du tout alors elle je vais te dire elle
a des défauts maiselle est pas
hypocrite comprend pas c'est la seule
chose qui fdère nous tous ici c'est le
fait de chanter la Marseillaise dans les
écoles comm des enfsêtre Français les
enant franais de P chanter la marseise
pouro tu
pas pas il problème a
laance à mon avis me semble-t-il Gill
que attends j'ai pas fini ma phrase
c'est que si jamais il y a des enfants
qui ne veulent pas chanter la
Marseillaise du coup toi tu devras les
condamner et tu sais très bien qu'il va
y avoir un séparatisme de certains qui
vont pas se sentir appartenir à la
France par rapport à la mar qui vous
Atta juste toi Atta personne d' arrête
de croire que tu as g derère elle a dit
que des enfants refuserai de chanter un
séparatisme VO VO mal
mal s'il te plaît
laisse don donc juste enfants ne vont
pas chanter la TER par ta lâcheté
idéologiissir oh là là mais c'est
exactement
comme TR de lâ je peux pas répquer c'est
exactement comme c'est exactement comme
uniforme tu ne veux pas l'uniforme parce
que tu es pour la BAA c'est exactement
la même chose les musulmans qui vont pas
chanter la Marseille ah voilà voilà
deislamophobie ordinaire ce que tu viens
de faire voilà
voilà VI faire
inadm quandz est pris est pris dans les
qu-
sortort à chaque fois
is tu sais quoi tu sors toujours
l'argument voil tu mets une cible sur
Géraldine ce qui est
inadmissible criminel et aujourd'hui je
suis Islam exactement
alorsens le dire Galine n'est pas du
tout
is tu vois non non mais non je veux le
dire parce que je vais avoir après tu
vas avir des gens sur les réseaux vont
écouter ce que dit ver qui vont écouter
les Conner je dis juste que quand toi tu
n'es pas pour l'uniforme et que tu
défends la BAA c'est justement pour moi
alors que moi au contraire je suis
laïque moi je suis pour que tous les
enfants de la République a le droit à à
tout tu vois à égalité et qu'on se
singularise pas par sa par sa religion
et toi malgré tout tu fais un petit
séparatisme et je pense que c'est
également pour ça que tu n'es pas pour
la marseillais tout le monde le dit Gill
déteste la France voilà regardez
regardez les réseaux ou je suis celui
qui est le plus arrête un tu sais quoi
tu es le plus hypocrite en fait tu sais
quoi tu sais ce que tu es tu sais je
vais te dire tu es comme toutes les tu
es comme le CEL tu vas être à toutes les
tables et ça je vais te dire bah si je
vais te dire tu es comme le CEL tu V
être à toutes les tables en même temps
et en plus tu adore c'est Go royale tu
ador c'est royale et c'est royale elle
est pour la Marseillaise exactement
comme comme le sel je vais retenir que
ça toi tu es comme le sel tu vas êes à
toutes les tables et quand on est à
toutes les tables et ben on mange pas
parce qu'on fa je te le dis bah c'est
toi tu bouffes à T le
atelier je te demande pas ton avis parce
que je peux dire juste une chose quand
même parce que effectivement je trouve
ça très dangereux de traiter quelqu'un
d'islamophobe parce que l'accusation
d'islamophobie dans notre pays elle a
déjà tué exactement merci et d'ailleurs
je peux porter plainte ouis non mais
Gill tu peux pas dire ça Géraldine mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai dit bon allez
d'accord regarde le replay ou regarde le
replay c'est bon
euh regarde on va regarder le tiens le
sondage encore une fois voilà qui va
montrer encore voilà comme d'habitude
Verde il pass jamais des 20 % Meur
scoreme pas besoin de les obliger tu
juste tu leur apprends en fait c'est
quelque chose qui fait plaisir un enfant
il un enfant parissence il aime son pays
a même pas besoin de mettre le verbe
obligé et d'ailleurs depuis tout à
l'heure tu as aucun argument c'est c'est
pathétique vraiment tu as pas
d'arguments mis à part dire je veux pas
obligé comme ça tuas aucun argument
aucun argument parce que c'est qui les a
données arum il veut pas les donner les
enfants ils sont fiers d'apprendre une
chanson ils sont contents ça rassemble
tublig mais mais vous comprenez rien ou
quoi mais tu tu veux leur apprendre le
texte et pas le chanter c'est ridicule
oblig à
chter je vais te dire est-ce que tu as
ne crois pas que les musulmans n'aiment
pas la France il ils aiment la France
ils aiment tous la France ils aiment
tous chanter la
marseillisein plein potes musulmans là
j'ai plein de potes musulmans qui disent
nous on veut chanter La Mar aussi je ve
la chanter mais
arrête
président
maxin pay même pas genre Deb en Grèce
les enfants ils
apprennent gre sont t cont
ousous tu sa quoi quand on aime
quelqu'un tu sais les paroles ne compent
pas sont les actes c'est comme avec une
personne tu peux dire que tu aimes Fatou
fais des actes pour pour mon tu l'imes
mais la France c'est pareil tu dis que
tu aimes la France
mais r REM tous les enfant
Réant républ question alors la meilleure
preuve c'est que Macron a demandé hier à
ce qu'on renforce les cours
d'instruction
civique oui c'est le respect c'est la
morale c'est le respect du drapeau de la
devise et donc tout ça est dans va dans
le même sens fait nation tous
ensemble France c'est pas aux antipotes
des valeurs de gauche qu'est-ce que cha
l'impression tu veux je te dise la
vérité parce que je pense que tu es tu
es mentor j'ai envie de dire tu es
mentos ou tu es mentor M très bien qui
c'est les ment sont un peu comme toi
pour moi ils n'aiment pas la France qui
veulent la détruire et qui veulent le
chaos je vais te dire ils veulent le
chaos ils veulent détruire la France il
ils veulent le chaos et tu veux que je
te dise tues mentors n'aim pas la France
donc peut-être toi aussi j'aim puis que
ils veulent qu'une chose tues mentor
c'est que il a le Cha en France pour
pouvoir prendre le pouvoir veulent
prendre le pouvoir par le
CH le Français sur Les fronton des
écoles non je pense que ça le Cho est-ce
que tu es pour le drapeau français ou on
met le drapeau mais le regarde pas alors
c'est comme la marseill on le met on le
regarde pas j'ai juste
dit voulez que je
redise pas un argument mais je veux pas
j'ai pas besoin
d'argumenter onoblige pas les enfants à
chanter La
Mar est- qu'ils sont obligés de le
chanter aujourd'hui l'hy
je vous voulez la trè
République hymne national chant
par on
veut nous tu veux on veut le respect des
profs on veut on veut le respect de la
police on veut respect des on veut le
respect des des infirmiers des
infirmières on veut le respect de tous
les gens qui travaillent et on veut et
on veut et on ve tu sais ce qu'on veut
on veut une France et c'est pas ta
France je te le dis je vais te dire qui
soit F et on veut une France qui
privilégie et qui récompense la France
qui travaille bien sûr non mais je te le
dis et non pas la France qui profite du
système je te le dis voilà et toi toi tu
alors je peux te dire tu peux je pense
pas que tu sois tu sois de cette France
là excuse-moi de te dire ça je pense pas
que tu es envie je pense pas que tu as
envie que on privilégie la France de
ceux qui travaillent et qui se lèvent t
le matin qui se couche tard le soir et
qui vous allez voir le témoignage qu'on
va voir tout à l'heure vous allez voir
20h45 je veux que tu regardes ce
témoignage parce que ça va te montrer ce
que c'est tu voir ça tu vas voir ce que
c'est c'est ton antirance tu vois non
non c'est pas ta France je suis désolé
toi tu es la France des assistés voilà
je te dis des squaturs et des profiteur
du système je te dis c'est ça ta France
mais c'est surtout que tu tu politises
des notions qui sont ni de droite
i j'ai rien dit j'ai pas dit de droite
de gauche j'ai juste mais tu donnes
aucune explication donc c'est là oùend
pasant est oigé d'aller à l'école un
enfant il va à l'école il est obligé de
faire de Ch normal c'est un cadre un
enfant c'est cadré c'est pas un électron
libre qui fait ce qu' veut dans la
VI il y a pask qui pourrait défendre
duile non même pas merci
pai tu veux es pour que qu'est-ce que tu
dis pourquoi tu Patriot ben moi je
trouve que même par exemple sur les
réseaux maintenant quand on met le
drapeau de la France les gens il disent
ah la personne elle est raciste parce
qu'elle a bien de la France c'est
fou on peut même pas obliger les enfants
à chanter la Marseillaise on est pas
dans la merde mais c'est ça exaement a
qu'un seul moment on a le droit d'avoir
un drapeau français de chanter à mercis
c'est pendant la Coupe du Monde c'est le
seul moment ex sinon on a Gill verd sur
le dos ti il il il
fait je vrais just